parce que
[Musique]
qui va retourner sur sa terre à toi
c'est pas rien retourner dans le pays de
ses ancêtres la grande aventure pour
retrouver ta mère biologique on est si
fière
[Musique]
ok t'inquiète
trop célèbre
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai compris j'ai eu
l'agence d'adoption et ils disent
qu'elle vient bon ok vous venez avec moi
mais oui grave
bonjour ça fait plaisir de voir une
Américaine tu fais quoi comme boulot
c'est les flics il fouille les sacs
[Musique]
on dirait une capote si on se fait
coincer avec de la drogue en chinois
[Musique]
si tu sais pas d'où tu viens
comment tu peux savoir qui tu es on peut
encore la retrouver nos passeports sont
dans ma valise celle qui a été volé vous
savez qui peut passer la douane sans
souci les stars de Kpop je crois pas que
ces filles soient des chanteuses les
filles montrez-leur c'est un peu attends
oui mais elle est là
[Musique]
pas une porte c'est mon trou du cul